ADAM MICHELSON: Hi, and
welcome to our Cloud Next
session on load balancers.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about the next generation
of our Cloud load balancers.
We've introduced many
new features recently.
And we're excited today
to share with you some
of what those features entail.
But first, let's talk--
let me present to
you our presenters.
So Adam Michelson--
I'm a product
manager at Google
Cloud, and I help
run the Cloud load balancers.
Babi, do you want to
introduce yourself?
BABI SEAL: Hi, everyone.
I'm Babi.
I'm also a product manager
on the load balancing team.
Thank you, Adam.
ADAM MICHELSON: Awesome.
So with no further ado,
let's dive right in.
So today, we're going to talk
to you about three items.
One is next-generation
load balancing.
We've been working to
re-platform many of our load
balancers to include advanced
traffic control capabilities.
Our load balancers have
been re-platformed to run
on top of the Envoy
open source system.
And if you're familiar
with the Envoy system,
then many of these features
may be familiar to you.
And if you're not,
that's totally fine.
You don't need to
know that platform
to use our Cloud load balances.
We'll also be talking about
how using this common platform
will enable you to have common
capabilities across our load
balancers as well as common
control planes across our load
balancers.
Next, we'll also be talking
about load balancing
everywhere.
This is a feature where, if
you have services that run off
of Google Cloud, such as
on-prem or in a multi-cloud
environment, how you can
connect to those services
through our load balancers--
so if you run services that
are not running on
Google, you can still
access those services
via our load balancers.
And finally, we're going
to talk to you about some
of our enterprise-ready
features,
such as Private Service Connect,
which enables you to connect
to third-party-- or services
that are not necessarily
under your
organization's control,
as well as how you can connect
to third-party applications.
So first, we're going
to talk about some
of our next-generation load
balancing capabilities.
So for the folks who may not
be familiar with our load
balancers, this is a quick
overview of our load balancers.
We have a few load balancers
in our load balancer fleet.
We have both a set of Level 7
HTPS load balancers as well as
Level 4 network load balancers.
Most of the next-generation
capabilities
you're going to see in our
Level 7 load balancers.
So as we were saying,
many of our load balancers
are getting an upgrade, where
we have advanced traffic control
capabilities brought by Envoy.
Now, Envoy, as I said earlier,
is an open source platform.
If you're familiar with
the Envoy platform, then,
again, these services
may be familiar to you.
One of the commitments Google
has is to the open source
community.
And this is an
example of that, where
we work with the Envoy community
to contribute features back
to that community.
And then we consume
those features
into these load balances.
So as part of that
capability, you'll
see our load balancer have
consistent set of features,
also consistent with the
open source capabilities.
And through that
consistency, you'll
see common control planes,
common observability,
and common feature set
throughout our load balances.
During the initial release
of our load balancers
that support our
Envoy, you'll have--
you'll see many new features.
Here on the right, you'll see
examples of what those are.
I'm not going to go
through all of them,
but I'll call out a couple.
So one example is weighted
traffic splitting.
Weighted traffic splitting
is used when you roll out,
for example, a new
feature or a new service
and you want to
test that service,
such as running a canary
test across those services.
Weighted traffic
splitting allows
you to take a certain
percentage of your traffic--
1%, 2%, 5%, 50%, what
have you-- and push it
to the new service
you're rolling out.
Another example is
fault injection.
In this example,
you can emulate what
would happen if you had
a fault in your system
before it happens in production.
That way, you can
harden your deployment
to make sure that when errors do
inevitably occur in production,
you've had an opportunity
to test them using
fault injection, as an example.
Now, this advanced
traffic control capability
of our load balancer actually
extends beyond just load
balancer capabilities.
For those who, again, may be
familiar with using something
like an Envoy sidecar, this
example may be familiar to you.
For those who are
not, Envoy, again,
is an open source component
and platform which
handles traffic management.
We have some of those
capabilities built natively
into our load balancers.
And again, you don't have
to understand Envoy at all
to use our load balancers.
They're just native features
of our load balances.
But for deployments that
are heterogeneous by nature,
multicloud, or on-premises,
and you want a common feature
set of traffic control
across Cloud and on-premises
or multicloud and you want
common policy management
and control, you
can deploy what's
called an Envoy
sidecar, which is
a deployable piece of
code that can deploy next
to your services.
And those sidecar will contain
traffic control capabilities.
And if you wish, you
can use a component,
such as Google's
Traffic Director, which
is a managed control plane that
can push XDS configurations
and controls into your sidecars.
And it doesn't have to be Envoy.
It just has to be an
XDS-compatible service.
So if you do that, then you
can have some services sit
behind Google Cloud
load balancers
and other services that have
a sidecar sitting next to them
in Google Cloud or
on-premises or in multicloud.
And in that architecture, you
can handle a highly distributed
set of systems running
across heterogeneous systems,
but running as if
they're running
in a homogeneous environment
because they're all
standardized using the Envoy
traffic control capabilities.
They'll have common features.
They'll have common
control planes.
observability.
Let's run through
a quick example
of how this might be useful.
So in this case, imagine
you're an e-commerce provider
and you have a shared service
across many components--
in this case, a wallet service
that could be maybe a payment
processing engine.
Now, here we have
an e-commerce engine
that will use the external
global load balancer
to access that service.
We also have,
potentially, a call center
using an internal load balancer,
which is, again, hitting
the same common service.
And on the right
side of this picture,
you'll see the tension is point
of sale using regional load
balancers, or maybe there's
nightly batch jobs running
on-premises, maybe
running fraud protection.
So in all these cases,
you have a common service
that these various
systems are using.
So what happens if
you want to roll out
a new service, a
version 2 of the wallet?
Each of these
disparate systems need
to be able to test that
service using something
like a canary test.
That's pretty complicated to
do if each of these systems
has its own capabilities.
And some may or may not have
weighted traffic splitting,
for example, built in.
But if you're using something
like an Envoy platform
everywhere, then you can use a
common weighted traffic system
across all these systems.
This will be the same
capability, the same control
planes, the same observability
to see if features are working
or if they're not working.
And in this way, you can go
ahead and test a secondary
wallet service--
say, version 2--
and see if that service
is working as expected.
And once it is, then
you can push all traffic
to that new service.
And so in this way, if you
do have a highly distributed
set or a complicated
architecture that
has reusable
services, whether it
be just a distributed set
of services or a system
like service mesh, you can use
advanced traffic management
that's built natively
into our load
balancers and other
components to reduce the toil
and overhead of managing
a highly distributed
set of services.
So now what I want to do is
run you through a quick demo
to see this live in action.
In this demonstration,
we're going
to see how to roll
out a canary test.
Here, we see four
different services--
in the upper left, a
global load balancer,
lower left-- regional load
balancer, upper right--
an internal load balancer,
and in the lower right,
we see a sidecar proxy.
Here we're rolling out
the various commands
required to be able
to do our canary test.
Now we're seeing that some
traffic is switching over
from version 1 to version 2.
And over the course of
about 30 seconds or so,
all the various traffic
management solutions,
load balancer and
sidecar proxies,
are beginning to send their
traffic to both version
1 and version 2.
The purpose is to make sure that
version 2 is handling traffic
properly.
At this point, we see a lot
of traffic going to version 2.
So now we're going to say that
everything is working properly.
And we're going to
send all of our traffic
now to the version 2
and away from version 1
and do our full rollout.
So again, we have the
same four services.
And we're going to run
the commands, which
are going to be common across
these various services,
to be able to switch our traffic
onto the new, updated version 2
wallet service.
And once again, it takes
about 30 seconds or so
for all the services
to get the command
and to switch all their
traffic over to version 2.
And so now you see that all
the traffic at this point
has been switched to version 2.
And our canary
rollout is complete.
Now that you've seen how
the next generation of load
balancers can enable advanced
traffic management capabilities
across a highly distributed
set of services,
I want to turn the
conversation over
to Babi, who is going
to run you through some
of our capabilities around
load balancing everywhere.
Babi?
BABI SEAL: So one of the goals
of our Cloud load balancing
is to meet you where you're
at in your journey to Cloud.
And as part of that, we have
gone ahead and introduced
hybrid load balancing.
So what is hybrid
load balancing?
You have clients that could be
external to Google or internal.
They send traffic to our
external HTTPS load balancing
or external TCP proxy or our
internal HTPS load balancing.
These load balances have
back ends, of course,
on Google Cloud.
But now we've enhanced them
to also support back ends
on-prem and in other clouds.
These on-prem and
other cloud back ends
are connected to Google
either via public connectivity
across the internet or
via private connectivity
through HA VPN or interconnects.
What we're really
excited to share
with you is that we have
now in public preview
our hybrid load
balancing with support
for on-prem and other Cloud back
ends via private connectivity.
And we support health
checking of these back ends.
And we'd really like
for you to try them out.
So how are some of our customers
using hybrid load balancing?
What are some of-- a use cases?
The most
straightforward use case
is load balancing to
workloads on on-prem.
More concretely, you can imagine
an ERP application running
on-prem [INAUDIBLE] regional
extension connected to Google
via partner interconnects.
The second use
case is protecting
your on-prem workloads against
DDoS attacks with Cloud Armor,
or you can use identity-aware
proxy to authorize access
to your on-prem resources.
You can enhance the latency
experience for your end users
by caching static
content on CDN.
The third use case uses
weighted traffic splitting
that Adam had alluded
to earlier to do
a gradual migration of workloads
from on-prem to Google.
Now we are working on
additional use cases,
such as supporting failover
from on-prem to Google.
As we develop more and more,
we shall share them with you.
Now let us turn our
attention to how
we are enhancing our enterprise
users with hybrid load
balancing use cases.
So what we are focused on is
reducing the operational toil
and meeting the scale
and security requirements
for our enterprise users.
In this regard, first let
us look at Private Service
Connect.
So what is Private
Service Connect?
In typical customer
deployments, you
have multiple teams producing
services for consumption
by other teams.
The groups offering
these services
could be part of the
same organization
or they could be third-party
services or services offered
by Google.
The way you typically
set this up securely
is via private
connectivity by setting up
peering between the
producer and the consumer.
But you run into a lot of
operational toil and scale
constraints with peering.
Now, this is where Private
Service Connect comes in.
It is our converged service
connectivity offering.
Because it does this through
private connectivity,
it is secure.
You don't have the
scale constraints
that you have with peering.
And it can scale to
thousands of endpoints.
It is also very performant.
You get line rate because there
is no proxy in the middle.
Now, how does this Private
Service Connect actually work?
Well, you have a
producer and a consumer.
And the producer--
you set up the service
behind a load balancer and
a service attachment point
in the producer's address space.
This service attachment
point is linked
to endpoints in the
consumer's address space.
The workloads in the
consumer, wishing
to access the endpoints,
simply send traffic
to the endpoints in
their own address space.
So how does load balancing work
with Private Service Connect?
Let's start with the producer.
The internal HTPS load balancer
and the internal Layer 4 load
balancer helps you
scale out your service
and makes it highly available.
Now, remember how
I was referring
to hybrid load balancing?
The internal HTPS load balancer
now supports endpoints on-prem.
So you can use the
Private Service Connect
to offer a service
residing on-prem securely
without having to worry about
overlapping IP address space.
On the consumer
front, we are now
working on putting these PSC
endpoints behind our HTTP load
balancers, external or internal.
With the URL maps that are
associated with these HTP load
balancers, you get fine-grained
control and selection of which
producer services
that you route to.
You also can now log
every service invocation
with our HTPD load
balancing logging.
In addition, for external
services that access HBS load
balancer, you can
put a Cloud Armor
and protect against DDoS attacks
or use our managed TLS offering
to secure the service further.
Now I'm excited
to share with you
another capability that we have
enhanced for our enterprise
users.
And that is integration
with third-party appliances.
So a lot of our
enterprise users,
as they migrate to
Google Cloud, wish
to bring their favorite
third-party appliances
with them as part of
the lift and shift.
With our ILPS next hop, we
have made it very seamless
and scalable integration
of these appliances
by our bump-in-the-wire
mechanisms.
What we have done is gone ahead
and enhanced that with three
additional enhancements.
The first one is support
for symmetric hashing.
When you have these multiple
stateful firewall appliances
and you have
bidirectional traffic,
you need to ensure
that the return
traffic hits the same
instance on the way back.
You typically do this by
configuring [INAUDIBLE]..
But there's a lot of operational
toil associated with it.
But now, by using symmetric
hashing with our Layer 4
internal load balancer
for bidirectional flows,
you no longer have that
constraint and toil.
The second enhancement
that we've done
is we've enabled all
protocols to flow
through ILB as next hop,
not just TCP and UDP.
So now, by allowing
ICMP packets through,
we'll be able to support
ping and trace routes
so that you can better
troubleshoot your flows.
Last, but not the
least, we've also
added tagging support
for your load balancers.
What this effectively does
is it allows you to group
a certain set of endpoints
with a tag and associate them
with an ILB and route your
traffic from those clients
specifically to that ILB.
The most common use case
has been regionalization,
where you can tag all
workloads in a specific region
and associate them with that
ILB in that specific region.
We have a very compelling
roadmap of our load balancing
offerings and features.
Let me share some
of them with you.
If you look at this
roadmap across the board,
we have multiple flavors and
features of our load balancing.
What I'd like to
bring your attention
to is in the Security
column, you'll
see that we've made TLS 1.3
the default for our HTPS load
balancers.
With perfect forward
secrecy, getting
rid of old, less
secure ciphers, we
made our solution more secure.
By cutting down on the
handshakes and the setup
latency, we've resulted in
a much more optimal end user
experience.
On the scaling front,
if you'll notice,
we've added support for
Layer 4 ILB [INAUDIBLE]..
What this allows you to do is
to scale your back ends, more
than 255 of your
Layer 4 load balancer,
and, hence, scale out
your service much--
now let me hand it off to
Adam to wrap this session up.
ADAM MICHELSON: Thank you.
Thanks so much, Babi.
So I wanted to thank all of
you first who joined us today.
And I hope you
enjoyed our session
and found it informative--
and also wanted
to present to you
other networking sessions
that are happening if you're
interested in other topics.
And of course, with
our load balancers,
we'd love it if you would
have the opportunity
to try them out.
And we always are
interested in--
to hear your feedback in
terms of which features
are working for you
and what enhancements
you would like to see.
So with that, I'd
like to thank you,
on my-- for-- on my behalf,
and then Babi's, as well,
and we do hope that you enjoy
the rest of your Next sessions.